this week you got Paul found that we
remainders are more intolerance of
brexit us than the other way around and
I don't just mean not letting up on the
fact that breaks it is wrong which of
course they are rather more than a third
of remainders would be upset if a close
relative married as strong leave
supporter and almost two-thirds say that
all or most of their friends share their
stance on brexit this is otherwise known
as an echo chamber
by contrast levers are comparatively
more likely to say that they have
remained supporting friends and are also
significantly less likely to be
concerned by any supporter in their
family these results are bitter pills to
swallow buts one of them we must Rex it
is dividing families friends and
political parties will come to offer but
perhaps some of this division could be
avoided if we remain as who see
ourselves as more open-minded what does
it practice what we preach
this doesn't mean compromising our
deeply held beliefs it does mean though
being more empathetic towards others who
don't share them there's a schism
there's a split there's a divide and
that's why that's about an
understatement yes indeed that's why I
was greatly heartened because I was in
Phil's dressing room just before the
show his favorite magazine the Tattler
because you know he's never without 2017
now there's nothing more important on
the dating scene than how someone voted
in the EU referendum yes dating a new
app called hater allows people to match
up according to what they can't stand
Greg and Carol come to mind it's data
shows that a staggering 88% of users
matched up according to their mutual
loathing for leave or for remain single
people need this kind of technology
because it's a biological fact that you
cannot tell whether someone is a
remainer or a lever by looking at them
effort or even by having sex with them
sorry about that they smell the same
feel the same it's just their brains
that are different the rules for dating
in a post-it breaks at University of
Tatler so we've moved on a little bit we
now look at thanks to research from
YouGov top brands for leave voters and
among the top 10 let's take a look at
the logos HP sauce Bisto iceland PG
tipps and richmond sausages and
there are 10 top brands of course there
are four remain voters here they come
among that 10 Instagram the London
Underground air B&B Twitter and easyJet
I'll tell you what I'm gonna pack that
up completely it's on the brand thing I
was outside the cool my shop the other
day this little kid come out to me and
say can you get me 10 Richmond so and I
bought him some sausage bacon butty an
age resource I where's my easy jet fuel
a question right so you got lever lever
lever and remain that's right so would
you accept to leave in your family a
loved one you marry Oliva I would
constantly challenge them and give them
a massive header here probably the best
romantic relationship in my life I'm
involved in the moment and she's like I
would try and convert them I would make
them convert I'll make them see sense
make them how would you enjoy it open
sir otherwise my missus she just it's
Carol Gretel because if you like that
means actually and you just thought that
it would be the leaders all related they
really they believe they occupy the
intellectual high believe you occupy
come moral high ground which in your
heads justifies the stuff say you Satan
it's supposedly believers nor the
biggest a very quick story I was at a
dinner party when the leave campaign was
going on than the remain campaign the
jus the referendum and a friend of mine
had 10 people referred in him and he had
a placard he's a very smart guy plaque
are he's gone
leaf vote leave yeah so this guy comes
the doorknob the dawn said he was common
for Danai was a guest and he actually
said is that is that you
and my friend said well of course oh I
can't come in our country yeah I can't
you know how and then the next morning
was so my friend let him go the next
morning you got the pole had been ripped
out of the ground that's remain remain
is anything they occupy them Oh Jacob we
had a few words of silence and he does
feel the same as me because I always
feel that you're beating me with a stick
your stupid feel you don't know what
you're doing
scaring me and all the rest doing stuff
right can you really do on this scale
okay let's see what let's see well Jacob
come on coop get up stop where are you
that's one of the problems of the
remainders they've always thought that
anybody who doesn't agree with them is
stupid and they thought the seventeen
point four million people who voted to
leave the European Union is stupid it's
a desperately condescending and arrogant
played he feels exactly the same as I do
every time I sight we were a minor my
point of dude okay you don't know
nothing feel you know you know and you
just get I just I do think I do think
we're right I don't think we have the
moral high ground as we lost the vote
but I do think we're right why isn't
good idea that Jacob Riis MOG is the
voice of the masses against these up a
theme tell you why I don't accept what
it's saying magic it's not what I'm
saying I will agree with the premise
that I think and it's been said more
frequently recently that I think we need
to learn how to disagree well yeah yeah
and I do think that we need to try and
build bridges between I'm not I don't
think it's helpful to create this huge
cultural schism between people in the
leave silently remain fight and I also
don't accept the premise that we're like
different species you know that breaks
the tears that these kind of crazy nut
jobs or that leap remains what we call I
don't I don't I don't accept I mean I
speak we boated leave or reasonable
people you made a decision I don't agree
with the decision there are a few
extremists and just like there are can I
explain why don't agree with imagine
saying the difference between the leave
in the remain side is that the remain
side voted to preserve the status quo so
and the leave side voted for something
radically
different so what you're saying is all
about and I've read the studies about
how people who voted remain are more
likely to lose sleep they feel they get
anxiety about it they feel extremely
strongly about it leaves them more
relaxed than wanting to be friends with
people from the other side that's that's
the study you're talking about right the
reason for that is that people who voted
remain are really worried that this
could have massive changes it could rip
families apart people people from EU
countries are worried about finish
remainders are worried that there are
going to be problems traveling that
people that British people in European
countries might be stranded there are a
lot of changes that make remain as
anxious leavers voted for a radical
change that they believe in just any
opportunity to stick a spanner in the
work so that this finger apples gonna
happen we remain as hatred of the
biggest-ever Democratic vote spills
easily over into as a spin on what I
think perhaps is an interpretation of
what you've said I think I'm not
convinced that's the reason and the
reason is if anxiety is causing the
remainer
intolerance then I would suggest at this
late stage breck citizens can face
anxiety because it they're not sure
they're gonna get brexit yeah leaders
are changing their line they are not
changing their leaders did say that they
were exploit intolerance in that so pain
can be among the
big I have an intolerance or anything
because of Richmond okay okay that's a
great plug for them I expect free
sausages for us to be like